um i follow mark wahlberg on instagram
every time i see mark robot on instagram
it's a [ __ ] new video about how he
woke up earlier
i wake up at 7 00 a.m and i get working
out i wake up at 7 00 am
am and i carry kettlebells i carry
kettlebells from one end to the other
gotta wake up at six a.m gotta wake up
at six am
and you gotta push this [ __ ] thing
that football guy's push
and you gotta put the weights on it and
i gotta push it from one end to the
other guys woke up at five a.m
woke up at 5am and i'm basically
building sandcastles
i got a bunch of dumbbells but i put
them to the side i woke up at 8pm
the first the day before hey
everybody i woke up at 8pm the day
before when did you go to bed i went to
bed after that but
miraculously i woke up earlier than that
what
i'm going back in time every time i go
in bed i go back in time and i wake up
earlier than when i went to bed
the [ __ ] i'm the only guy who does it
aspire to be better
i wake up before i go to sleep huh